this is a very interesting story that we have
to talk about.
Hillary Clinton decided to go after 2020
Socratic presidential candidate Tulsi gathered
over the weekend.
Telsey Gobert has fired back and the most
important top line analysis of this entire
story is that this is the best thing to ever
happen to Tulsi Gabbert and I'll explain why.
Hillary Clinton did a podcast interview with
David Pluff who is or a Barack Obama's former
campaign manager and during this interview
she made a bunch of different claims.
She said the Russians are leveraging numerous
American politicians, Russia may have compromised
meaning compromising information about Donald
Trump.
She says she believes that 2016 green party
presidential candidate Jill Stein is a Russian
asset and she suggested that Tulsi Gabard
is backed by Russia and might even be supported
by Russia to run third party in 2020 which
could potentially spoil the election for the
eventual democratic nominee and help Donald
Trump get reelected as president of the United
States.
Her exact quote is quote, they're also going
to do third party.
Again, I'm not making any predictions, but
I think they've got their eye on someone who's
currently in the democratic primary and are
grooming her to be the third party candidate.
She's the favorite of the Russians.
They have a bunch of sites and bots and other
of supporting her so far.
So this then sets up Tulsi to fire back at
Hillary Clinton in a series of quite frankly,
pretty wacky tweets, but it doesn't even matter
at this point because Hillary has stepped
in its so severely, uh, Telsey Gabbert saying,
great, thank you Hillary Clinton, you the
queen of warmongers embodiment of corruption
and personification of the rot that is sick
and the democratic party for so long have
finally come out from behind the curtain.
From the day I announced my candidacy candidacy,
there has been a concerted campaign to destroy
my reputation.
We wondered who was behind it and why.
Now we know it was always you through your
proxies and powerful allies in the corporate
media and war machine, afraid of the threat
IPOs.
It's now clear that this primary is between
you and me.
Don't cowardly hide behind your proxies.
Join the race directly.
The reason that this is wacky is the same
reason that Telsey has been wacky owl, a wacky
all along, which is that Tulsi Gabbert has
been pretending or claiming that the DNC and
the establishment are stopping her in the
2020 campaign in the same way that they stopped
Bernie in 2016 this is delusional and I'll
explain why momentarily, but the main point
is this attack by Hillary against Tulsi is
the best thing that has ever happened to her.
Tulsi Gabbert has been pulling on average
between 0.6 and 1.5% I believe at the latest
she was averaging 1.2% in the polls.
She never had a shot at securing the nomination
other than a few moments in debates.
She made Tim Ryan look bad in one debate.
You know, that's the one that stands out to
me.
She had a couple of other moments, no traction
other than, you know, her followers say she
gets a lot of web searches after debates,
which doesn't seem to be helping her polling
at all.
She hasn't even made all of the debates.
She's got bad takes on a lot of issues.
She's dabbling with Republican framing all
the time.
Check out her recent interview with cultural
critic Dave Ruben as an example, and so what
Hillary Clinton is doing by attacking Tulsi
Gabard is helping her fundraising potentially
going to help her polling, maybe help her
qualify for the fifth debate in November,
which she otherwise may not have as a few
days ago.
She had not qualified for it.
The tide has been turning more and more against
Tulsi Gabard because she's saying more and
more ridiculous things about the Kurds and
Syria and Modi and the DNC and Assad, her
bogus grandstanding threat to boycott the
fourth debate, which of course she didn't
do.
It was clear that Tulsi was about to disappear
and incomes Hillary Clinton and revives attention
for Tulsi Gabbert a very dumb.
Now let me address Tulsi and her followers
framing Tulsi as the screwed candidate of
2020 just like Bernie was screwed in 2016
this is a ridiculous comparison.
There are two main differences between Bernie
2016 and Tulsi 2020 and they're not small
differences.
The differences are public support and progressive
change makers.
Okay.
Bernie Sanders pulled as high as 47% in 2016
he had gained the support of nearly half of
the democratic primary voters.
Tulsi Gabbert has not pulled more than what
two in some polls, three maybe in one poll
in the entire primary.
Tulsi Gabbert does not have and has never
had the support that Bernie had in 2016 so
to equate the campaigns and to argue that
the DNC and establishment have screwed Tulsi
just like they screwed Bernie out of the nomination
is laughable and anyone who believes that
that is a case that can be made empirically
either doesn't know the facts or is deliberately
not paying attention to them.
That's number one.
The second difference between Bernie 2016
and Tulsi 2020 is that Bernie's 2016 campaign
was a progressive campaign that actually ran
on shaking up the establishment status quo
of campaign finance of health care on a long
list of issues that have become progressive
mainstream.
In 2020, Bernie's progressive, 2016 candidacy
really threatened the establishment and changed
the way that democratic politics is done with
the huge growth of the progressive wing of
the democratic party.
Tulsi is running more and more to the middle.
She's not for Medicare for all.
She is not clearly, uh, even in favor of impeaching
Donald Trump.
Uh, even for the inquiry, she's not clearly
for defending the curds and on and on and
on.
She's running on the repeated slogan no more
forever Wars in a geopolitical vacuum.
There are people who have fallen for that
and said, that's the progressive hero.
That's just, that's great.
That's progressive.
Uh, but the idea that her campaign is anything
like Bernie's in 2016 in terms of the impact
it would have on the establishment and the
impact that it has on challenging the status
quo is ridiculous.
But in the end, thanks.
Hillary Telsey may now last a little bit longer
thanks to this entire thing and just yet another
major, major misstep by Hillary Clinton.